こんにちは！！はじめしゃちょーと…
魔…
みなさん野球って知ってますか？
野球
もちろんそれはね
国民的なスポーツですからね
野球ってバットというものがあるんですけども
これで基本的に
野球をします
ピッチャーがボールを投げると
それを、このバットで打って
ンッフフ・・・
アハハ
ちょっと違うww
まぁ、大体ね　ニュアンスがそういう感じ
というわけで今日はですね野球のバットで
ビヨンドバットというのがあるんですよ
バットのここら辺がゴムで
なんかで出来てて
打つと、すんごい飛んでいくんだよね
ぶつかったことはある
はじめ：すごかった？　まさき：すごかった
はじめ：普通のバットより全然飛ぶ？　まさき：飛ぶ
ちゃんと当たれば
ダメだね
うっふっふはっ
ビヨンドバットなんて使ってらんね～や
今回はビヨンドバットを超える
もっと
ぶっ飛ぶ、最強のバットを作ろうというわけで
今回は！
カンッ！！
輪ゴムを今回1kg分買いました
待って待って
想像の8倍くらい多かったんだけど
これはちょっと
BAD(バット)だねぇ～　バットなだけに
はい、というわけでですね
こちらに輪ゴム1kg分準備したので
今回はこのバットのここに
ビヨンドバットみたいにたくさんゴムをつけていきます
ビヨンドバットに比にならないぐらいの威力になると思うので
1kg分の輪ゴムをつけた
最強のバットの弾力性を活かして
甲子園に…
あ、ダメだ
頑張ってる甲子園球児に
馬鹿にするなって言われそうだから
地元のクラブ球団に勝つぐらいの
打球力を手に入れたいと思います
いや…
もっとやっぱ、上を目指そう
メジャーリーグを目指したいと…
うわぁ～
これヤベぇ～な…
引っ張ればいいんですか？
××××× じゃないか
ハハ、やめて
これちょっと待って
ほんとにヤバイ
ほんとに、××××× みたい
よだれ出ちゃった
ハッハ、大好き//
～♪
ちょっと待って、思ったより付かない
これを四方向全部やろう
うぉお～
オッケー
くっ、くぅううううううう～
あぁああああああ～
ここだ
そこ！
オッケ、オッケ
んゥ、んんんんぅうううう
おっしゃぁ～
輪ゴム1kg、バットに付け終わりましたぁ～
これねぇ・・・
キツイっすよぉ！？
キツイっすよぉ・・・
まじで、手がもう・・・おかしくなっちゃうぐらい
というわけで今からこのバットを使って
はたして、普通のバットと比べて
どれぐらい飛ぶかっていうのをね
実際に打ってみようと思います
弾力がもう・・・かなりヤバイ
やばいねぇ　ヤバイ、これは
絶対、普通のバットで打つより
確実にホームラン率は高いんですけども
ちょっと、気持ち重い的な？
振れないんすよ、なかなか重くて
ヤバイ！！重い！！
どれだけ、こう…気楽にホームラン飛ばせるかを
ちょっと実験でやってみようと思います
ではいこう
プレイボール！
まさき：いくよ
はじめ：はい
アッー
ボール！
普通に打てるじゃん
ダァアアアアー！！
おっ！
うぉー
はじめ：惜しいんじゃない？
まさき：惜しくねーわ
あ、ごめん
わぁああああ！！！
打ち上がった！
ヒット！！
まさき：それ、体力使うよねぇ～
ヤバイこれ
よし、来い
わぁあああああ
お、すげ、でも…
まぁ、アウトっすわ
気のせい　気のせい
待って、ヤバイヤバイ
ちょ、審判…
試合中にあるまじき行為だから
うぉおぉ～っと、俺 ビックリしたぁ～
あ、あ、あぁ
待って、重い 重い ヤバイ
ンフッ
あぁっ～～
打ち上がった
ハッハッハッハ
うわぁ～
劣化しってってますね
色が白くなってきています
うわぁ、やべぇな　重いだけかもしんない
打てる気はするんだけどなぁ～…
わぁー
わー、ごめん
わぁ～イッたぁ！
あぁ～
いった、いった
ナイス守備！いいよぉ～
オッケ～イ
次、行ける？
次、行けるよ
来る、コレ
アッー
あぁ～　ごめんッ
ごめん、ごめん
アハハハハハハ
一番、飛んだ！
おぉ
よっしゃぁ
オウッ！
ﾝﾊﾊﾊ
おっ…
あぁ～、これは
わぁ～、ごめん
気をつけ！
礼！
ありがとうございました
気をつけ！
礼！